[APPLAUSE]
KENNY NGUYEN: All
right, guys, we're
going to have a
little bit of fun.
But before we have a
little bit of fun today,
I'd like you all to
get to know about me.
So a little about me is-- can
we pull up the slides, please?
--is I love creating
amazing presentations.
And when it comes to
amazing presentations,
this is what I love right here.
It's very detailed--
this guy right here
is like there's no way.
I'm joking with you.
Really what I love
doing is simplicity,
but before we get
really into what
I love doing in
presentations-- I
feel like this just killed
half of this audience,
thinking oh my God,
what did I sit down?
Let me introduce a
little bit about me.
And so a little bit about me is
that I am a proud Cajun-Asian
born from Louisiana.
I am from Baton Rouge, and this
is actually me in my thug life
years about 10 years ago.
So I had a very interesting
creative journey.
And during this time, we had
a lot of different things
that I loved doing, such as
I loved playing music-- which
is actually a funny story.
This is my co-founder
Gus right here,
that's him all the way to
the right with the Afro.
We played a lot
of music together,
and I always thought that being
a musician would be my calling.
I wasn't that good.
And Gus would probably
say I was kind of good,
but he's being nice,
don't believe him.
And I figured at that point
that maybe creativity in music
wasn't for me.
So I decided to go
on a different path.
And the next path I came on
was I wanted to be a chef.
And I trained for four years as
a cook in Asian food-- sushi--
but also I trained
in Italian food.
I really thought
that this was going
to be my calling in creativity.
It wasn't, I lost a
culinary scholarship
because I missed a competition.
And because of that, I
actually left the country
and went to Vietnam
to go find myself.
And in Vietnam, I
had this crazy idea.
It was-- I always
loved the subject
creativity and communication
and conversation.
Music, food were really intimate
ways to communicate that,
but is there another way that I
can communicate and help others
with my passion of
communication and conversation--
whether it's through
music or food?
And decided how about I just
go to college-- at this point,
this is when I was in
high school-- I actually
go in and create a
student organization.
And so I created an
organization-- how many people
know where LSU is?
I'm a very proud LSU
Tiger fan, and at LSU we
created an organization
called IME, which is I
Am Entrepreneur.
And it was funny because I
had the student organization
and didn't own a business.
And it was even
crazier that I managed
to get a lot of really
great CEOs in the room,
locally, talking about
entrepreneurship.
And it made me think
what if I could
help these guys with their
PowerPoint presentations
because they were so boring?
And it was just in
the back of my head.
But the story gets even funnier.
I remember-- it was in January
2012, it was actually me
and Gus-- we were sitting
in a room for our student
organization, and I remember
there was a Fortune executive
coming to speak to us.
And I remember I was so
excited-- I was young,
I was naive, and I
thought Fortune executive,
he must be an amazing presenter.
There's no way he could be bad.
Well, soon lo and
behold, I remember
he walked up and
had a USB drive.
And he plugged in
his slide deck,
I remember seeing
in there 200 slides
at the bottom right
corner of his PowerPoint.
I'm thinking oh shit,
and at this point
this guy-- scheduled for an
hour-- went on for three hours,
reading off every single slide.
And to make it even
worse, this guy started
telling his own jokes,
answering his own questions--
And as I was sitting
there it made
me think-- if the world
and these companies
are presenting
like this, chances
are the next big
idea won't be heard.
And that's when we had
an idea of why don't we
create a firm that can
help these executives,
help these companies create
amazing presentations?
And that's when we had the
idea of Big Fish Presentations.
And we never thought
the idea would take off,
it was a college start-up.
It was one of
those ideas that we
had where why don't we just
help a couple companies here
and there?
But soon enough, people
started noticing us.
We got in Inc. Magazine as
one of Inc.'s coolest college
start-ups, that was really neat.
And that's when the
Fortune companies actually
came calling us
and saying, can we
get you guys to help
with our presentations?
And we thought maybe we have
a really cool and crazy idea,
and we should just run with it.
And so as we evolved more,
Entrepreneur covered us,
and we started getting
more clientele.
We worked with clientele
like Ted, Verizon, and GE.
And soon enough, we actually
worked with this guy.
And it was really
cool because we
worked with this
organization called the Hult
Prize down in-- actually here.
It was during the Clinton Global
Initiative, the huge summit
they had down here.
The Hult Prize is $1 million
for the biggest college
start-up that's
helping the world--
and in nonprofit as well.
And what was so cool is
that we helped a Dubai team,
and it was such an
amazing experience.
Because after the whole entire
show we helped the Dubai team,
Bill Clinton walked up
to us, shook our hand,
and said that was an
amazing presentation.
And that's when we
thought OK, wow, we're
actually doing something right.
So this is some validation.
So a little bit about me was
that that's our journey so far.
And from that, we
have a book-- which
is actually located right
over there, "The Big Fish
Experience."
But even further and even
better than all this is now
my girlfriend agreed to marry
me, and so I'm now engaged.
And so I joke with
her all the time
when I show this slide-- was
it all that that led to this?
She's like no, don't show that.
But a little bit about me,
I'm a very happy engaged man.
This actually happened
at Disney World.
But with all these things
that happened with Big Fish,
we've learned there's
a process in creating
amazing presentations.
And while I know you're so
interested to hear my story,
I know you're really
interested in hearing how
to make amazing presentations.
And we have a process, and
that process is actually
called the Big Fish Experience.
And it's content,
design, and delivery
equals an amazing
presentation experience.
And we're going to go through
those three things today--
this content, design, delivery.
I know we have a whole
entire range of people--
from designers,
to app designers,
to even some business
development people in here--
so we're going to talk about
a lot of different ways.
From the basics--
how can everyone
walk away here and create
an amazing presentation--
but even more, how do you find
a way to become the best version
of yourself as a presenter?
And the first thing
that we're going to do
is actually content.
And so our content-- part of
the design delivery process
is that engaging
content always wins.
But what does engaging
content really mean?
So with content, there's
four different things
that I always
recommend when it comes
to making a great presentation.
And this goes from whether
it's a deck that you're
going to send out,
to a pitch deck,
to even if you're
pitching an idea.
And the first is that
every single presentation
that you have should have
this thing called a big idea.
And a big idea is an
idea that formulates
around the whole
entire presentation,
it's your central argument.
And by the way, in the
middle of this talk
we're actually going to create
a presentation from scratch.
So we're going to
have a lot of fun.
So the big idea is the
main central argument
of your presentation.
It's what people are
compelled to believe in.
And furthermore with that is
that every good presentation
should have a structure.
So when I say structure--
how many people
here know about the rule
of three in presentations?
So the rule of three in
communication and presentations
is that if I tell you there
are six things to remember,
there are five
things to remember,
it's a little bit
more difficult.
But if you're able to condense
your presentation down
into three easy
points-- they're, I say,
Twitter handles-- you're more
likely to walk away and have
someone to be able to
retain the information.
The next is a call to action.
Every presentation--
I tell you this.
When I think of the
word presentation,
I don't think of just
the formal presentation
we're doing here on stage.
I think of going home,
talking to my fiancee,
and saying what do
you want for dinner?
Then I present my ideas,
she presents her ideas,
and we go back and forth.
It can even be a
conversation, or if you're
pitching an idea such
as a design concept.
Presentations can be anything.
But here's the thing-- any
time when you go and present
an idea or just
an argument, it's
important to have
a call to action.
And when I say call to action,
there are three different ones.
One is an offer, such as
if you buy this, you'll
get X. Next is demand, do this.
And the next and final one is
actually more of a question,
such as what if you went
home and ate a donut
and became happy?
And the reason
why I say donut is
that that's actually
the presentation
we're going to create.
We're going to create a
live and full argument
on why everyone in
this room who might not
think donuts are healthy,
would now believe
that donuts are healthy.
And so we're going to do it
with the same exact process.
So from going around this
room, how many people
here actually love donuts?
Good, there's not that many.
I love this.
All right, challenge accepted.
So how many people here don't
think that donuts are actually
healthy for you?
Kind of wrong,
but it's all good.
Donuts are delicious, though,
they're great for your mind.
They make you happy.
And so with that
being said, that
will be the central argument.
The big idea is that for all
the donut lovers in here that
now have my back, we're going
to create and work on a reason
why everyone else in the
room should love a donut.
So just going around, why
should people in this room
love donuts?
And this is where
I'm going to ask you
questions, because we're going
to come up with our own pitch
together.
AUDIENCE: There are so many
different kinds of donuts.
KENNY NGUYEN:
Exactly, there's so
many different kinds of donuts.
What else?
AUDIENCE: They taste delicious.
KENNY NGUYEN: They
taste delicious.
Come on guys, this is the
time to rise up and talk
about donuts.
AUDIENCE: They're flling.
KENNY NGUYEN: They're filling.
AUDIENCE: They make you happy.
KENNY NGUYEN: They
make you happy.
AUDIENCE: Sugar rush.
KENNY NGUYEN: Sugar rush.
AUDIENCE: They're America.
KENNY NGUYEN: They're
America, there you go.
So let's create this
central argument.
For the donut lovers
in here, what if we can
say that donuts make you happy?
That's a good enough reason
why people should believe,
because I don't think anyone in
this room wants to be unhappy.
Now let's think of
a call to action.
And I always say when you create
a presentation-- no matter
what it is-- think about the
call to action at the end.
Where do we want to lead people?
Where do we want to take
them on this journey?
Because if you have a big
idea and you have an argument,
there's always a chance
and there's always
a reason why you should create
your call to action first.
And that's because
you should know where
you want to take your audience.
So for us, then, donut
lovers-- call to action,
let's be a little bit gentle.
Let's say if we ask them
if you want to be happy,
why don't you get a donut?
Do you all feel like
that's an enticing enough
and non-forceful
enough conversation
for the non-donut
lovers in here?
You think so?
Cool.
So our main idea-- and
imagine this as a circle--
is that donuts make you happy.
At the end of the
presentation, our big ask
is why don't you get a
donut to make you happy?
Now comes the fun part
when it comes to structure,
creating the three main
points to convince people.
So I heard three main
points-- I probably
won't say it's
America for this case,
but let's think of
some main points.
If I were to come in right
now and pitch someone
that doesn't like donuts
why they should like donuts,
and the main point is to make
them happy, what would you say?
Start pointing at
different people
now is-- I heard earlier
that someone said that they
have a sugar rush, right?
And you like sugar rushes.
What's another one?
And this is what we're going
to build up for our structure.
They taste good.
And tasting-- you like to eat
food that tastes good, right?
Exactly.
So let's say the main point
one is they taste good.
What's main point two?
They're what?
AUDIENCE: Cheap.
KENNY NGUYEN: Cheap?
America.
[LAUGHS] So yeah, they're cheap.
What else?
Let's have our third point.
Let's hit it home here.
Come on, guys.
We've got to help.
AUDIENCE: Sugar helps your
brain function in the afternoon.
KENNY NGUYEN: Damn, so that
was a really deep answer.
So we're gonna
close off with that.
So let's say this.
If I came up and
pitched-- and I will
give this whole presentation
right now about donuts
is that, one, like,
they taste delicious.
Two, they're cheap.
But here's the thing,
being cheap and delicious
can actually make
you more productive,
because a sugar rush will
help you out in the afternoon.
And overall, if you're
more productive,
you'll be more happy.
There is a very
compelling reason
that everyone can walk out
right here, right now and think,
I should go and get a donut.
Now, to close this whole
entire presentation,
pseudo-presentation
that we have right here,
it's always important to
remember your introduction.
And I say this with
so much importance,
and I waited till the
end to tell you this,
is that every presentation
should have an introduction
that's very memorable.
And there are five
different ways
to have a great introduction.
One is to build the emotional
connection through a story.
Two is to tell a statistic.
Three is to share a quote.
Four is to actually
deliver media,
whether I open up with a video
to kind of bring you all in,
make you all feel very
welcome-- 30 seconds to a minute
is what we normally, like,
recommend-- or fifth, I open
and tell a joke.
Jokes are dangerous, as everyone
knows, because if falls flat,
you're fighting an uphill slope
the rest of the presentation.
But for the sake of this
one, how about I actually
give this presentation by
telling a story and using
all the points that
you delivered to me.
So again, who are the people
that love donuts in this room?
Get my back.
Cool.
That's a lot of people.
We're going to convince
everyone else right now,
through your support, that
they should love donuts,
just from what you just said.
So, when I was a
kid, my father used
to bring home donuts
for me all the time.
And the reason why is
that he always told me,
you need to eat breakfast.
And I was a very energetic kid,
and for anyone that's actually
seen my TEDxTalk, I
actually shared a story
where I used to run around
all the time outside,
and it drove him crazy.
And he thought, you know
what, how about I just
stop feeding him donuts.
And he noticed that my energy
levels really went down.
And the thing is, he
wanted a happy kid.
And so, why don't-- why did
he take that out of my diet?
So it actually leads
to another story.
About two years
later, I was actually
at my brother's birthday party.
And in Louisiana, if you'll
ever go down to Baton Rouge,
there's this wonderful place
called Mary Lee Donuts--
and I feel like I should
get a sponsorship for name
dropping them-- but a delicious
place called Mary Lee Donuts.
I remember that my
dad took me here,
and he said, son, let
me tell you something.
I love you very much-- and he
never says this, and tells me,
furthermore, do
you want a donut?
And I was like, yes, I do.
And he said, well,
here's the thing.
You know, we never get
to spend time together.
Why don't you take a
donut and we can just
go and hang out and relax?
My father was always very busy,
so this meant a lot to me.
And so that moment
there, I realized
that donuts made
me happy and that,
if anyone ever asked
me about a donut
and we wanted to break
bread together, that this
was a really cool story.
And so I want everyone
here to believe in donuts.
So my presentation,
my argument to you
today is that donuts
can make you happy.
And here are three reasons why.
One is that they are delicious.
Who doesn't like good food?
Good.
No one raised their hand.
I'm very happy about that.
Two, who here wants to
spend a lot of money
on something that
tastes delicious?
Sure, we can go, like, a three
Michelin star restaurant.
Sure, we can go to a two,
one Michelin star restaurant.
But for just the
price of $2 or $5--
I'm using New York prices--
$2 to $5 right here,
you can have a delicious donut
and really make you happy.
But the third is the
most compelling point.
Everyone here at Google here
I know works very, very hard.
And I know that everyone here,
when they come in the morning,
you're energetic.
But as you go
throughout the day,
the brain kind of drains down.
You get tired.
There's so much
bombardment in our lives.
So what if there was a way,
what if there was a device
or something that we
can ingest, cheap,
that can totally make us
more effective as leaders
in the creative community?
And if we remember that
that device does exist,
and it exists in this delicious,
small pastry called a donut,
I believe then
that everyone here
will have a much more fulfilling
career and be much more happy.
And that's why yo should
go and eat a donut.
See?
That right there was
a very compelling way
to tell a story about the donut.
And if you follow that
format exactly how I
did in any of your
presentations--
say you have a big main idea.
If you have a project coming
up, explain why the project
is the best for everybody.
Next is to have
a call to action.
What's your big ask at the end?
What do you want
to lead them to?
Next, have your main points.
What are your main arguments?
Just from those five
minutes right there,
we came up with an idea of
how to make other people that
don't love donuts love donuts.
And finally, have an
introduction that's memorable.
If you're sending
out a presentation,
make it very simple in the
beginning with the design.
You don't want to just
jump and bombard people
with a lot of clutter.
However, if you're
going on stage,
I always suggest share a story.
That story is
actually a true story
that my dad always brings
home Mary Lee donuts.
I'm always very
energetic as a person,
so he actually cut
it off for a while.
But then he took me
to the donut store
for my brother's birthday.
That's a true story.
Now you actually know a
little bit more about me,
and I'm sure that
everyone here today
has a story about a
donut where they remember
the company that they were with,
and they want everyone else
to have that same happiness.
And so that's
content right there,
is that content can
be engaging if it
has a structure, a call to
action, and a big main idea.
But the next thing that's so
important in the presentation
process is that we
actually have design.
So how do you take content to
the next level with design?
And the way that we
do that is that we
have a very simple equation.
It's just simple, memorable,
and understandable.
And so when it comes
to simple, memorable,
and understandable
slides, I'll actually
share some slides that we
created with clients, including
one we did for the Hope
Prize for the Dubai team
that I think you all
really would like.
And so the first
thing is simplicity.
So everyone-- have you all
heard of the KISS principle?
Keep It Simple, Stupid?
It's one of those things that
goes into slides completely
well, because if you're
giving a presentation,
the focus should always be on
you, the presenter, and not
the presentation.
Keep this in mind.
People will always
remember the presenter more
than the presentation.
And so when I say simplicity,
this is what I mean.
This is actually a slide that
our team did for a client
where it's very, very simple.
And the thing is, everyone
here is wondering,
why don't I
understand that slide.
What is he trying to say.
And that's what it should be,
is that, at the end of day,
I need to be here to present
it to you for it to make sense.
However, after I
deliver my message,
this should ring home with you.
And that's my first
message to you,
is that, if you're
designing slides,
keep in mind is that if you
are needed there to deliver it,
that's a good slide.
However, though, if they
can just read the slide
and you don't need
to be on stage,
you're wasting your time.
So think about it like this.
Always keep it simple
when it comes to slides
because people need to see you.
Next is being understandable.
And so this slide
right here is a slide
that we actually send out.
And it's not cluttered.
And you exactly know where
your mind actually or your eyes
actually draw.
So it's in the top corner
to the bottom to the left.
And it's very, very simple,
but it's also understandable.
You know exactly the way this
means with this infographic.
Now, with simple
and understandable,
it should all come together.
And I'll show you one
of my favorite slides
that we've ever created
at our firm, Big Fish.
And it's this slide right here,
is that-- you might notice
it's kind of blurry, right.
And you might thinking,
man, that's a really shitty
designed slide.
And we did that on purpose.
And the reason why is
that, for the Hope Prize,
we had four amazing judges.
They included Muhammad Yunus,
one of the Nobel Peace Prize
winners, and also
Sanjay Gupta from CNN.
And what was so cool was that
we had an opportunity to tell,
with our client, the
story of Harambee.
And Harambee, you see, was a
very small little black box.
This company
developed a black box
that can make glasses for
$5 for kids in urban slums.
And that's amazing because,
if you think about it,
we can just go walk
outside this door
and walk, like, less than two
miles to go get a pair of Warby
Parker like right here.
However, though, imagine
a kid in an urban slum
where they couldn't do that.
Imagine not being able to
see, not being able to learn.
What can we do to
make that happen?
And the thing is, we actually
thought to ourselves,
what if the judges all
had perfect 20/20 vision?
How can they understand what
does it feel like to be blind?
And so we created this
slide right here when
we pitched to the company
was imagine if you were
a child growing up in Guatemala
and you couldn't see anything,
but you wanted to learn,
you wanted to lead,
and you wanted to
do great things.
But your sight isn't there.
And if you want
to be better, you
need to see the people
that believe in you.
And this is actually
what they pitched.
They said, for those here,
who here has 20/20 vision?
And the judges raised their
hands, and we were right.
And they never-- and
they asked, so you all
might not know what it's
be like to be blind.
However, though, if
you're looking right here,
this is what it's like.
But for $5, if you invest in
us today, you can do this,
and a child can see and
make a huge difference.
And they loved it.
And that was one of
most memorable moments
in that whole
entire presentation.
And it was one of those
feelings where I thought,
that's how design
can be memorable.
So for anyone here
today can take away
something when it comes to
presentations, whether it's
with content but for
design, is that simplicity
wins because they need
you, as the presenter.
They need to be understand
but, most of all,
it needs to be memorable.
There's no reason why
slides can't be fun.
PowerPoint is fun.
I know everyone, when
they come to our firm,
they think, what can we
do besides PowerPoint?
We have all these cool
tips and tricks in our bag,
but I always say, what's
wrong with PowerPoint?
You can do amazing
things with PowerPoint.
This right here was
done in PowerPoint,
but it delivered a
very effective message.
So with content design comes
one the most important things,
and that's actually
rules of thirds
is that, with every
grid slide here--
how many people here are
photographers on their off time
here?
So what do you-- when you
think of the rule of thirds,
you always think of
your central figure
should not be in the center
when you're creating a slide.
It's actually you want to be
able to position your figure,
wherever your main
point of focus
is, to the left or
the right so you have
a little bit of slide-- or
little bit of room to the left
or right to actually
put in there some words.
That's what we recommend for a
lot of our presentation slides.
For anyone going home
today and creating
their own presentation, think
about the rule of thirds.
If you put it in the middle,
you're forcing something.
But you're putting
to the left or right,
you're actually coexisting.
And that's what you
want with slides,
is that you want to coexist
when it comes to photography.
You never want to impose on top.
And here's some
of our other sides
that we created,
is that, for this,
when it comes to slides like
this, you think of photography.
This is very, very, very
boring energy usage.
How can you make this more fun?
And we see this in a lot
of corporate presentations,
is that you actually think,
OK, this gets the point across,
but how do you
make it memorable?
And this is what
I recommend doing.
Let's bold the important
points, and let's throw
an image at the end.
Next, what do you
think about when
you share a graph like this?
We all seen graphs
like this where
it's a chart or some kind
of information presented
and you think to
yourself, wow, what can we
do here to make it more fun?
Very simple.
Why don't we turn
it into a graphic?
And it's simple tools like
this where you can do it
and where you can turn very
minute and boring information
into something fun
and more lively.
Design should be fun.
And the thing is, like,
how many people in here
are actually designers?
I'm not a designer, and
I'm proud not to be is
because if you learn these
simple design principles,
anyone can become a great
presentation designer.
And I say that is that there
are many tools out there.
So this tool right here,
you can create something
using Canva, for
example, a very popular--
Canva or Piktochart
is another one.
And those tools can create
amazing infographics for you
very quickly.
If you're ever in a rush
for presentations and you
can't hire an agency or you
don't-- you can't just spawn it
off to another designer, I
recommend there's a tool called
Haiku Deck, and it actually puts
in your presentation content
for you and actually allocates
it into a way where it does not
feel like there's too much slide
or too much text per slide.
But there are many
good tools out there
to make you an effective
presentation designer.
It's just very important to look
for them and to keep in mind
that being simple,
memorable, and understandable
for any type of designer is
the most important thing.
Now this is the fun
part is the delivery.
So when it comes to delivering
slides, presentations,
or even arguments or
even conversations,
it's very important to have
powerful body language.
May I have a volunteer?
Preferably a donut lover?
May have a volunteer in
here to actually demonstrate
some good body language?
I'm going to choose you,
Gus, to come up here.
This is my co-founder,
Gus, over here.
And so-- whatever
I say, you do, OK?
Just trust me.
GUS MURILLO: OK.
KENNY NGUYEN: OK.
That's the way I sold it to him.
That's my presentation to him.
So, ways to have
better body language.
The first thing is
to always remember,
when you give a
presentation, no one
wants to have a grumpy
person in the room.
It's very important to smile.
So smile.
Let's smile at him.
Let's wake him up a little bit.
Just smile at him.
So it's very important to smile.
Smiling actually alerts the
other human in front of you
that you're ready and
you're ready to engage.
If you're grumpy and you're
walking up and you're sad,
it pulls off a very
different opinion of you.
Second is that you always
want an open posture.
Imagine if you're like this
talking in a presentation.
And it's one of
those things where
it's very hard to do
because, when you're nervous,
you're going up,
you're like, OK,
let me think about something.
It looks like you're not sure.
But you're open, it shows a
much more positive and more
engaging type of body language.
The third is to
use hand gestures.
So you can do this.
It's hand gestures.
And I say it in a controlled
way is that imagine I present it
like this.
You don't know if I'm excited.
And just by using
one hand, it shows
a completely different
way of saying
you don't know if I'm excited.
It seems very, very different.
That's the power
of hand gestures.
It can actually
show your emotion
and it shows your point.
The fourth is to actually
have eye contact.
So let's stare him down.
GUS MURILLO: Again?
KENNY NGUYEN: Yeah, again.
Sorry, man, you're in
my direct line of sight.
So is eye contact.
So I'll tell you all a secret
trick that one of my friends
taught me, is that
for those people here
that are very afraid
of eye contact,
there's a trick called
looking in the forehead.
I'm looking at your
forehead right now, man,
but it looks like I'm
staring directly at you.
It's very creepy, I know.
Just bear with me.
But the thing is, though,
that's a very effective way
is that, when you're able
to look someone in the eye
and tell them a message that
they might not believe in,
or an argument, a call
to action, a big idea,
but you're able to
look them in the eyes
and show that
genuine authenticity,
it's much more compelling
for you as a presenter.
But if I look away I'm
telling you something,
you want that attention on you.
And so that's why eye
contact is so important.
And the fifth and most important
point is do it naturally.
You should not
look like a creep.
Sorry, man.
We just totally just bombarded
you with some of that.
But if I'm just doing this
and talking, pull me out.
NYPD, come get me.
And you don't want that.
You want something that
looks very natural.
And that's why it's so
important to rehearse.
Gus, thank you, man.
GUS MURILLO: All right.
KENNY NGUYEN: So let's give
him a round of applause.
He had no clue, and that's
how I sold it to him.
But next thing is,
how do you rehearse?
Because when you
think to yourself,
body language,
oh, I can do this.
I know-- I remember
how to do this.
It's very important to
rehearse and create habits.
Presentations,
public speaking, they
become great through habits.
Sure, you can present
once or twice.
But if you don't-- aren't
able to critique yourself,
there's a very different
way for you to learn.
And I recommend three different
ways to actually rehearse.
One-- does anyone
ever record themselves
before a presentation?
It's really hard
to watch, right,
sometimes in the first-- yeah,
it's actually really miserable.
For my first-- for my TEDxTalk,
and actually the same talk
I did at HubSpot recently,
I actually gave a talk
and I watched it and I thought,
man, I don't like this.
And I watched it about nine
times, and I just said,
I'm gonna scrap it.
And that's really
flustering to understand,
but here's the thing, is
that if I'm able to do that,
I'm able to watch it
and say, if I'm not
able to sit through
my own presentation,
why would someone else want
to sit through it, as well.
And sure enough,
we redid it, and I
think the video now has
almost 40,000 views on YouTube
and 10,000 on SlideShare.
And it was actually telling
the story about "Shark Tank."
How did we make-- we
turned down "Shark Tank"
and in my TED Talk, we
explained how we turned
the process of "Shark Tank."
And the challenge is how
do you make that sound fun.
And so watching it over and
over and over again to the point
where we knew where
it sounded fun
and I would enjoy hearing the
story was that breaking point.
And so finding a way to rehearse
and watch yourself-- pull out
that webcam, pull out that
iPhone, watch yourself
rehearse and critique yourself.
Did you say something
that sounded weird?
Do you say a lot of
and's, um's, or ah's?
Or did you have
body language that
just made you look
boring, creepy,
or did you not enunciate
your words correctly?
It's very important
to record yourself
because then you'll find
your biggest critic.
Next is always find
your own unique ritual.
So my ritual before
I go and present
is I love listening
to stand-up comedy.
And it just makes me happy.
And the thing is, before
I go into a presentation,
I should be happy.
So there are different
ways for you to actually
prepare yourself mentally.
So does anyone
here want to share
some of things they do before
they go on a presentation?
AUDIENCE: I wasn't
at the TED Talk,
but there was a woman that
did a Superwoman pose, so I--
KENNY NGUYEN: Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's actually one of the
most common ones I actually
hear is, like, the
Superwoman pose actually
just gets you really revved up.
I think that's great.
I think I would love
to try it for myself.
I should do that.
Any other ones?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I like to listen
to Rocky's "Eye of the Tiger."
It gets me--
KENNY NGUYEN: Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
Music is actually
another big one.
Yoga I've heard.
Tony Robbins actually
jumps on a trampoline.
I've read that, like, before
he went on Dreamforce,
he just jumps on a trampoline
to get that adrenaline up,
those endorphins, and he gets
them really amped for, like,
his six-hour workshop.
It's incredible.
And so it's good, though, is
that you have these rituals.
And to prepare yourself is one
of the most overlooked things
is that, sure, I'm just
giving a presentation.
But you always want
to be in your element.
If you're able to find
what makes you happy
beforehand, that makes you
really energetic, use that.
Keep that in mind.
And the third is
to actually find
friends that can critique you.
And that's one of the most
overlooked thing, because you
always think, oh, you
know, I'm in this alone.
If you have people in
the room-- and I'm not--
I usually ask this
question, who--
how many people here in
the room have actually
wanted to fall asleep when
they've seen someone else here
present.
And usually it's a really
uncomfortable question.
I always tell them, those are
the people that you should
go to, because those are
the people that tell you
straight up that
will tell you you
can do better on
your presentation.
And that's very
important, is to find
those friends or those
colleagues, those coworkers,
those siblings that will
tell you straight up,
I didn't understand
what you had to say.
So to close, for
this formal part,
is that there are three
things that everyone
should remember when it comes
to an amazing presentation
experience.
One is that content
should always be engaging
and should always
have a structure
and should always, always,
always have a call to action.
Next is that design should
be simple, memorable,
and most importantly,
memorable and understandable.
Now finally, delivery.
Delivery, always
find your element.
Have that great body language.
But it's most importantly find
what makes you comfortable.
Because at the end of
the day, if I'm up here
and I'm teaching
you and telling you,
why don't you become like
Steve Jobs when you go present?
You're gonna think,
I'm not Steve Jobs.
You want to find
your own element.
And that's why we
have this process.
The process here isn't to teach
you to be like someone else.
This process here is
to teach you to be
the best version of yourselves.
And for people here that
know the poet Maya Angelo,
people always remember
what you say, what you do,
but people will never forget
how you made them feel.
That is the true essence
of an amazing presenter.
And if you remember that
quote in any presentation
that you give, it's how
you make others feel,
I promise you you'll be the most
amazing presenter in the room.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
for that presentation.
You guys definitely
know what you're doing.
So I have a handful
of questions about how
you can take all the
experience that you guys have
and how we can apply it to
our day-to-day work here.
So one of the first questions
I have is all this information
is pretty fantastic
if you have a week
to prepare for a presentation,
but the reality is
there's going to
be situations where
I get an email in
the morning and I
have to give a presentation
in three hours.
Do you have any tips
or tricks or advice
on how to prepare presentations
under a time crunch?
KENNY NGUYEN: Yes, I do.
And, like, feel
free to chime in.
For our stuff is that I actually
get pretty frequent requests
to do presentations if, let's
say, a speaker drops out.
I'll go and give a
presentation the day of.
And the best thing I've
always learned to do
is, like, I talked it a
little bit about earlier,
creating that type of
structure in your presentation.
The intro, three main points,
and then a call to action.
I make sure, before I go on
anything else-- design, or even
delivery-- I have that kind
of content right there.
Because at the end of the
day, that's your message.
And so before I even
open up PowerPoint
and you're in a
time crunch, if you
have less than six hours
or even less than two hours
to put together a deck,
that's what I recommend doing,
is, like, come up with your
structure and your message
before you take
on anything else.
I don't know, do you
want to chime in on that?
GUS MURILLO: And keep
in mind that content
is the most important thing.
You shouldn't be spending too
much-- if you have six hours,
you shouldn't be spending
five hours on your deck.
Focus on what
you're going to say.
Spend your last bit of
time putting-- making sure
that your slides look good,
but honestly just the biggest
tip is just keep it simple.
There's tools out
there like Haiku Deck.
Or if you just honestly want
to make something really
quick and simple in
PowerPoint, that's
good because, if you try to
spend too much time making
the most detailed
slides, it's not
going to matter if you're
not prepared for what you're
going to say and if you don't
have a clear and memorable
structure.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
A lot of these rules
sound really excellent
when you're giving
a presentation
to a large audience.
Do you think it
changes at all when
you go from a stage
and a platform
to a small room or
a conference table
and you're presenting to
a small set of coworkers?
KENNY NGUYEN: I actually learned
that by doing some workshops--
we do a lot of workshops--
I actually change a lot more
based on the audience size.
For example, if we had,
like, a stadium crowd here,
or, like, a crowd like 1,000,
for example, I normally
wouldn't do and engage with
them that much compared
to if it's a smaller room.
And so like, let's
say, like five
to, like, 50 people,
that's when activities
would be more-- I would be
more open to activities.
It matters because
the reason is is,
like, you can only engage
so much people in the room
at a time.
But the smaller it is,
let's make it more intimate.
Let's make it a conversation.
And so I'll tell
anyone that, like, when
they give a presentation, if
you have, like, a small room,
make it a conversation.
But if it's a
bigger room, that's
where a more formal
presentation would be OK.
I don't know, what do you think?
GUS MURILLO: Agreed.
Just make sure your activities
are tailored specifically
to your group.
Like, for groups of five to 10,
which a lot of small meetings
are, you can actually
get every one of them
to answer your question
and to chime in,
rather than here you have
to get a crowd to come up
with a few suggestions.
For a group to five to 10, you
can really get some-- a lot
of back and forth, and actually
turn it into a conversation.
Because groups that
small don't want
to sit for 45 minutes,
or even 30 minutes
and just be talked to
for that period of time,
they want to talk.
KENNY NGUYEN: Yeah,
everyone has a voice.
And that's why I wanted
to do the donut activity.
It's always fascinating,
because usually it's
like-- it's usually
a hit or miss
when it comes to people,
like, actually engaging back.
Because a small room,
everyone would just
start-- just bombard
me with, like, this
is why I love a donut,
this is why I love a donut.
And it's cool.
But, like, when it comes
to, like, larger crowds,
you know, you have the feeling
of, should I say something.
But once a person say
something, then we
have one person
that just chimes in,
then the others will chime in.
It usually takes that one.
But with a smaller room and
you have like 5 to 10 people,
usually you're getting
it left and right.
MALE SPEAKER: So Google
has the unique problem
where we might have a
meeting in the morning
where we're talking with our
coworkers on the same floor,
an hour later we may have a
meeting with our coworkers
in India or
California or Brazil.
Do you have any advice
on how to communicate
when you're doing it
digitally across [INAUDIBLE],
or something like that?
KENNY NGUYEN: Yeah.
So whenever I think of
presentations-- or webinars
or just doing something
remotely with colleagues,
like complete--
like this even comes
in when we do client
pitches is that we've
had to learn the hard way
on how to engage them.
When you do something
on the computer,
you're fighting with what's
available on the other person's
computer.
It's like internet, it's
YouTube, it's cat videos.
It's-- it can be anything.
And the way that we always
thought about it is this,
is like how do we
get it to be direct.
So I'll answer in two parts.
One is, if you
have a small group
for five 10 people,
that's when I
say I would engage with people,
is I would ask them questions.
I wouldn't just go
sit down and present.
And if I do, I keep that
at a minimum, where there's
a break in between where I
can ask them questions, what
do they think, and give a
time where they can actually
submit in questions in the box.
However, though, if it's
from, like, 25 to 50 people,
that's a little bit
different, where
it's a little bit harder because
you have a whole entire team
call and you don't know who's
really paying attention.
I mean, quite frankly.
So what I recommend,
in that case,
is that, if you use a slide
deck, keep it very simple.
If it's-- it's even harder
to present off a webinar,
because you're not there having
that personal connection.
So that simple, memorable,
understandable design
applies to that.
If there's no slide
deck, though, I
would recommend actually
asking questions and engaging.
But at the same time,
have an agenda call.
And clearly make sure who's
involved on that call.
I mean, you want
piggyback on this?
GUS MURILLO: Yeah.
Especially for smaller meetings
between-- and you're pitching
ideas, make sure
that you go into it
and they go into it knowing,
like, I guess an agenda,
but it's mainly
just a structure.
So they know that
they're gonna come away
with these few things.
And that might not be a deck.
Just make sure
that you have that
written down and sent to them.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So in the next
few minutes, we're
gonna open this up to the
audience for questions.
So if you have something
you want to ask,
please stand by one of
the two microphones.
So in your opinion, you know
how to give good presentations,
and so you probably have a sense
of what a bad presentation is.
What is the absolute worst
thing a person can do?
KENNY NGUYEN: Read
off 200 slides.
MALE SPEAKER: 200 slides.
KENNY NGUYEN: No, I'm kidding.
Well, like, no, the
worst thing I've seen--
and I hope everyone
takes this to heart--
is when the presenter
is everywhere,
there's no structure
in the presentation.
I kid you not, when you
have a structure, a roadmap,
you know where you're going--
and it can be suspenseful.
You don't have to reveal
everything in the beginning.
But if you have a
roadmap that can tell,
like, there are
three things we're
gonna learn today-- content,
design, and delivery,
you know where I'm taking you.
That's fine.
But if I'm telling you all
these different stories
and you don't know where we're
going, that's a big problem.
It's always to say, like, I
like to have presentations
that have a structure.
Still surprise me,
but at least, like,
let me know where we're
going, where we're at.
GUS MURILLO: And the
biggest thing for me,
since I-- I guess-- I mainly
contributed to the design
portion of the book,
was just everyone
putting too much on the slide.
And that just happened
so frequently.
It just-- keep in mind that what
you're gonna send to the people
later is not what you should
be showing to them right now
on stage.
And that's the
worst thing for me.
That guy with the 200 slides,
having 60 bullet points a slide
where you can't even read it.
That's the worst.
MALE SPEAKER: So the flip
side of that question,
are there any speakers that
you particularly look up
to or view as role models?
KENNY NGUYEN: I really like
Scott Harrison from charity:
water.
He's a very good presenter
because he's really--
he's able to tell very
emotional stories,
then deliver the meaning
to that story after.
And well, this
presentation I just gave
didn't have a lot of
stories, but you're able
incorporate more stories
in your presentation,
make it more personal,
you're able to connect more
with the other person.
That's personally my
favorite presenter.
And then, you know, you have
the Steve Jobs of the world,
or even-- you know, I
actually really like Malala.
Malala's a really good
communicator, as well.
So I have several
presentation heroes.
I never try to emulate
them, but I always
try to learn from them.
GUS MURILLO: I like
Scott Harrison,
from a design perspective,
because he's a photographer.
He documents his entire life.
And so from-- as a designer,
you can just visually see
him walk you through his story.
And just seeing him present,
it just helps it so much.
His slides aren't
a crutch, it's just
a way to walk you through
his life and his story.
KENNY NGUYEN: It should
always be an aid and not
a visual crutch.
And those rule of
thirds that we shared
earlier, that's actually a lot--
a big proponent of his slides
is that they always
follow the rule of thirds,
is that it's coexistence,
it's not overpowerment.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Great.
So let's open this up to
questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Great presentation.
Thank you guys for coming.
When I think about doing a
lot of presentations here,
oftentimes I may present
it to a small group,
but the deck will
live on forever.
People are going to look
at it, and I won't have
the opportunity to present it.
How does that change
the calculus of how
you're putting together a deck?
GUS MURILLO: The way we do
it is we make two pieces, one
for-- especially if you're
either on stage or in a meeting
room in front of people, you
make that deck completely
separate from what your
actual information is.
So you can work on your deck, if
you like to display everything
in PowerPoint or
Keynote or whatever,
you like to put all
your bullet points in
and what you want them to
remember and take away,
make all of that first.
And then make what you're
gonna present after that.
Make what you're gonna
present as a completely
different document
that doesn't live on,
because that needs you.
So that's the way
we-- and that's
a hard thing to remember,
because it's not--
you're not doubling your work.
Because in the end, you
just put all your work
into your structure
and your content,
and then just spend
the last bit of time
making a really simplistic deck
so people aren't overloaded
in trying to read that.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
You mentioned
PowerPoint and Keynote.
Hopefully you also
use Google Slides.
KENNY NGUYEN: Yeah, that was
one joke that Ben threw at me.
He was like, yeah, why
don't you use Google Slides?
I was like, if I have no time,
I promise you I'll switch over.
Unfortunately, we didn't today.
AUDIENCE: That actually
leads into my question,
is that you talked a lot about
the content and your body
language and
whatnot, your person
as you present the presentation.
But in terms of the
underlying technology,
do you still feel like a slide,
your traditional slide that's
been around for decades
now, is still the way to go?
And sitting here at
Google, among some
of the best and brightest, are
there any changes or feature
requests that you would
like to put out in the world
right now to help
make your jobs better?
GUS MURILLO: I don't
think that the slide would
be-- I think it's an option.
I think it's a way for people
to display information.
But I honestly am starting
to like the way that we just
cut out the deck completely.
Write it on a white board
or-- like Simon Sinek
draws his own paper.
And I'm starting to
find that as a way
to-- for people-- for
seasoned presenters or people
who can get on stage and are
comfortable with complicating
what they're doing on stage,
but it's just such a cool way
and a different way,
because it's not
the deck that's been living on.
It's even older than that.
It's before that.
It's just drawing it out
for people to see it live.
And it changes, and will change
from what the audience says.
So slides work, but I guess
I'm starting to be partial
and starting to, like, a lot
of the engaging presentations
are finding different ways
to display the information
outside of the computer.
Going back.
KENNY NGUYEN: Yeah, actually
so for my TEDx Talk, what I did
was, like, I actually
cut out all my slides.
And it's funny,
because people always
suspect me to have, like,
this amazing sideshow.
But I actually normally don't
use slides in my presentations.
I usually use an easel
and a white board.
And this is why it's
kind of new for me
is, like, when I use decks,
I'm, like, thinking, oh man.
Like, I like to
be like-- kind of,
like, run wild almost,
but at the same time,
like, have that, like,
canvas of creativity.
So that easel and that
white board really helps me.
But one thing that
I really, really,
really like doing in some
of my pitches and, like,
my presentations
is having props.
I like to do show
and tell a lot.
So my TED Talk was talking
about why we turned down
"Shark Tank," but the
underlying message
was the power of
saying no, and why
that's so important
in people's careers
and in their personal lives.
And I use the anal-- or
pretty much the metaphor
is that a sword is like yes,
but a shield is like no.
And I gave that
analogy to people
and actually pulled out a sword
and a shield after my talk,
and I remember people were,
like, going crazy over it
at the end of my talk.
I had this, like,
really cool moment
of my life where I
remember just, like,
putting the sword in the air
and the shield in the air.
But it made a more
memorable presentation.
So if you're able to use
props, that show and tell
type of element-- I know
Cisco does that really well,
and Apple does that,
as well-- I think
that's another element
to your presentation
that goes beyond the slides.
It's like, show people
why you're so excited.
GUS MURILLO: And
one feature request
would be, as you connect
to the audience, which
is why I like the
hand-drawn way to present,
is, like, no platform is
very good at integrating
social and then getting real
live, like, live feedback
during a presentation.
Especially, like, tying into--
there's a few out there.
There was one by the agency--
an agency out of-- like one
of the big agencies.
And they created
a lackluster app
that kind of does it and
pulls in some feeds and stuff,
but it's not that good.
And there hasn't
been a solid platform
that allows people to pull
in real time social feedback.
So as a feedback
request, it's something
that I haven't been able
to found-- find to suggest
to people, that'd be one.
KENNY NGUYEN: I would love
for one way, by the way,
if you all can incorporate,
when virtual reality becomes
more commercialized, I would
love to find a way where,
like, the slideshow can actually
extend beyond just the slide
and take you to a different,
more immersive experience.
And whether we develop that
in-house ourselves or, like,
even Google develops
it, like, that's
one thing I'm really interested
in the future of presentations
is virtual reality.
Like, even like, you
know, just seeing
on screen putting on, like,
a pair of glasses and, like,
and just seeing it, just being
something completely different,
that's that wow factor
I hope I'll see one day.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, guys.
Well, we're almost out of time.
So to wrap this up, you
covered a lot of topics today.
If there's one thing
that everyone here
remembers and takes away from
this, what would that be?
KENNY NGUYEN: Mine is
that people will always
remember the presenter
more than the presentation.
And you should never,
ever, ever, ever
deliver a presentation
you wouldn't want
someone else to sit through.
GUS MURILLO: I would say
just in creating your content
and working through your pitch,
make sure you keep everything,
from content to design,
as simple as possible.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Great.
Well, this has been Kenny
and Gus with their new book
"The Big Fish Experience."
Thanks for coming, guys.
KENNY NGUYEN: Thanks
for having me, man.
GUS MURILLO: Cool.
Thank you.
KENNY NGUYEN: Appreciate it.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]